hi there steve goffman here i'm leaving
today with my wife we are going to south
to spend a month in the sun because it
rains here hello the month of october in
vancouver has been unusually dry
i'm quite happy to stay here in the rain
play my old-timers hockey three times a
week go skiing up at uh
cypress cross-country skiing 21-20
minutes from uh where we live
but my wife watches the rainfall every
day and
likes to go
south for november which is the rainiest
month here in vancouver
so i don't know whether i'll be able to
do videos down there so i thought i
would do at least one here before
leaving
and i want to talk about memorizing
vocabulary with a little bit of
reference to the conference again
uh on multilingualism and cognitive
processes that i attended at mcgill
first of all i can't answer the various
comments and questions
that have appeared below my
my videos here at youtube because
youtube is completely messed up in terms
of how they deal with with comments and
the ability to respond to comments if i
get a comment and advice by email if
there's been a comment to reply or to
respond click here and it takes me
somewhere
it doesn't open up underneath the
comment that i'm supposed to be
responding to
uh very often that comment is not to be
found
it looks like there's a total um
the whole
system
and whereby they deal with comments is
completely messed up it never was great
uh then for a period it seemed to be
working better and now it's completely
messed up i hope they fix it even if i
click on my inbox i can't get to the
list of
comments that have been recently made so
that i can comment on them if anybody
has any advice on that please let me
know
memorizing vocabulary there was uh uh
one of the people i follow on facebook
anthony louder
who is that great uh
self uh uh
facing
uh brit who studies
czech and other languages based in
prague
and he asked people what their favorite
way it was for memorizing vocabulary so
i wanted to talk a little bit about that
in my opinion the best way to memorize
vocabulary is
not to memorize vocabulary
i have always found trying to memorize
vocabulary whether from a list
whether in flashcards
or however
any deliberate attempt to memorize to
put to memory these items of vocabulary
is
an extremely
low efficiency activity no matter how
hard you try
some words are going to stick and some
words will not stick
until much much later
so i don't do that
i believe
that the best way to acquire vocabulary
is through lots of exposure
and
you know meeting vocabulary items in
different contexts and the more
content you consume through listening
and reading the more likely you are to
encounter
these vocabulary items again and every
time you encounter them again you
encounter them in different contexts
which makes the whole you know
scope of their meaning clearer each time
you get a better sense of which words
they are used together with
you really start to experience these
words in live settings and also in
settings hopefully that are high
resonance if you are listening to
content of interest such as when i
listen to my
uh
czech you know
tolkiesco mindlessly which is
interesting stuff
about czech history if the content is of
interesting it's higher resonance and so
you really want to kind of get a sense
of the meaning of these words in that
context then you see it again in another
context
to me therefore trying to memorize it on
a list i think that may go into
short-term memory some things will stick
but a lot won't so it's to me it's a low
efficiency activity it's also a boring
activity and i always have the feeling
when i'm devoting time to sort of
studying a list of vocabulary i'm
stealing time away from
meaningful interaction with the language
as in listening and reading and or
speaking and and speaking is also
important i don't want to underestimate
speaking it and perhaps i have given the
impression
that i only work on input i don't it's
just that input is easier to arrange but
i was at an evening the other night here
in vancouver there was a russian
language meetup and there's no question
that after
sitting for two hours and speaking
russian left right and center the
quality of my russian
goes up and my attentiveness to russian
goes up and i notice that the next time
i listen and read
and so you do need to also speak but
meaningful speaking
meaningful listening and reading
that's all meaningful interaction with
the language
it's high resonance and
as you encounter words hear words see
words use words eventually in those
contexts to my mind that is a better use
of time than trying to memorize lists of
words so exposure is key and i think
this came out
in the conference uh in montreal where
they analyzed you know i'll give you an
example
uh from memory here but so many of the
the
sort of case studies or research
examples that were presented
uh were very very limited in scope
and and you'll have an opportunity to
check this out on their website i left a
link to their website in my last video
and you can also
you know google multilingual conference
mcgill university and you'll find them
but one example was one presenter talked
about attrition in l1 your first
language and used as an example
an italian
comparing italian immigrants who had
lived in canada for 10 years to italians
in italy
and the reaction of their brain
to
sort of word order
that might be acceptable
in in italian
um
i can't remember exactly either that had
been influenced by english word order or
a word order that was acceptable in
italian but very unusual and so that the
reaction
by and large by
italian immigrants who had lived in
canada for 10 years the brain reacted
differently to those
changes in word order than the brains of
italians in italy and there was also
differences depending on the
degree of or the level of education of
people and so forth
i mean to me that's relatively
uninteresting it seems to me obvious
that a person who lives in canada for 10
years will be influenced by english even
in their native language that doesn't
mean that there has been attrition in
the language and and
i don't think it demonstrates even if
people start to introduce
essentially non-native patterns in their
italian i don't consider that attrition
because it's just
necessarily you will be influenced every
language you learn is going to influence
you in some way in the languages that
you already speak that doesn't mean
attrition and as one commenter said on
my previous video it would be very
interesting to see why it is that many
of us experience
this improvement in our language when we
take some time away from it to study a
third language i've experienced it and
other people have said the same uh you
know i i lived in japan for nine years
didn't touch mandarin chinese
hardly spoke it at all come back to
mandarin chinese i'm better
i decided to spend some time on swedish
listening to swedish audiobooks didn't
touch i can't remember what other
language i was on i come back to that
language maybe it was italian i
understand it better and so this whole
idea of
not only is exposure to the language
you're studying important but exposure
to language learning and all this sort
of exposing your brain to different
languages and different structures and
different sounds
seems to have the
effect
of making you
more attentive to the language and as as
you'll remember i firmly believe that
language learning really revolves around
three issues your attitude
you know how motivated you are
uh
to improve in different aspects how
interested you are how how much you like
the language
time the amount of time you spend to it
therefore exposure and also the ability
to notice and exposure in itself makes
you more attentive to the language
that's not to say that other activities
can't also help and and i should also
close here because we're getting close
to 10 minutes uh it's not that i never
study vocabulary i very often
whip through my flashcards say i'll at
link before
studying a new lesson i'll review the
saved links the words that i have
already encountered before and um in the
process of learning some of which i have
now learned i'll review them in
flashcards
often if i have five ten minutes to kill
while waiting somewhere i'll review my
flashcards but i always have my flash
cards with all the information on the
front you know the hint as we say you
know the translation and on link
the uh
the actual term the translation and the
captured phrase
which we capture like and i review them
all on front so again it's exposure i'm
not
racking my brain trying to remember what
this term meant because i personally
find that
uh unes
inefficient and tiring and and stressful
and uh
boring so i i always say that to
memorize vocabulary give yourself more
exposure mostly in interesting content
but if you are going to review words and
of course you don't have to do it my way
but i'm just telling you what i do so
even when i review words say in
flashcards it's more of an exposure
activity going through them quickly
to give myself more exposure
occasionally reviewing the same phrases
that we have in link
so this i hope i'll be able to do some
more videos down south i may even try
using my uh
my iphone i saw richard simpkon did a
video from iceland and he seemed to have
his iphone held at a distance so i might
just try that and see how it works out
anyway i hope we get i know we'll get a
lot of sunshine down there
well it's it'll be probably it'll be
raining here in vancouver so thank you
for listening bye for now